hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute möchte ich etwas
anlässlich zu ostern backen und zwar
gibt es einen leckeren oster kranz ich
werde den jetzt füllen es gibt ja auch
uster grenze die sind einfach pur aus
hefeteig ohne füllung mit hp zucker
obendrauf
aber ich bin es immer so ein bisschen
leckerer wenn man eine füllung drin hat
deswegen kommt heute im mandl und
marzipan füllung rein
zuerst bereiten hefeteig zu und zeigt
euch mal die zutaten
ich hab hier 500 gramm mehl 100
milliliter milch drei eier einen würfel
frischhefe 50 g zucker ein bisschen
vanille extrakt zwei esslöffel bares
wasser und eine bio zitrone von der
brauche ich die schale und zuerst starte
ich jetzt damit und nehmen einen wasser-
und lösbaren jetzt die hilfe auf einfach
so ein bisschen schummeln
da kommt jetzt bisschen zucker mit reis
und das vermisse ich jetzt einfach damit
sich die hefe im wasser auflösen kann so
da kann sie sich später ganz einfach
besser aufgehen
dann gebe ich diese hefe mischung
einfach in meine küchenmaschine ich mach
das jetzt halt in der küchenmaschine
aber ihr könnt den teig auch gern mit
der hand verkneten
die schüssel die spiele ich jetzt
einfach mit der milch so ein bisschen
aus bleiben doch nicht so viele rechte
drin
dann kommen da auch die eier mit rein
dass man die lage
und mir fällt grad auf ich hab das salz
vergessen nämlich noch einen teelöffel
salz mit rein hole ich aber gleich dann
die schale lockt einfach sind für die
frische im hefeteig und passt auch echt
gutes marzipan und jetzt gebe ich noch
etwa die hälfte bis drei viertel des
mails mit dazu lasst es schon mal
verkneten und wohl komplett sonst
jetzt hier noch den restlichen zucker
mit rein
ich gebe jetzt hier noch meinen
teelöffel salz mit dazu dürfte recht
nicht vergessen das ist ganz wichtig und
100 gramm weiche butter hat die gebe ich
jetzt einfach auf ein spiel mit ein
es ist halt einfach gut weich sein
jetzt gehe ich einfach nach und nach
mein restliches mehl dazu und das ist
nur richtig schönen glaubte teig
verkneten
der hefeteig dürfte jetzt etwa sieben
minuten lang nähten
das ist auch ganz wichtig damit er
einfach nicht so klebt und ihr stetes
jetzt hier auch zwischen schöna weiter
hefeteig ich habe jetzt hier auch
diesmal mehr eier mit drin
normalerweise habe ich ja immer nur ein
ei in einem käfig aber dadurch wieder
einfach so ein bisschen kuchen artige
einfach so ein bisschen lockerer und
jetzt knete ich ihn einfach mit der hand
noch mal kurz durch und man sieht auch
ich brauche kein mehl und es klebt
nichts man kann den schönen formen so
einfach zu einer kugel
jetzt müssen wir ihn nämlich nochmal
aufgehen lassen das mache ich jetzt hier
nochmal in einer schüssel ich kann die
maschine auf 30 grad einstellen
ansonsten könnte einfach ein
geschirrtuch oder frischhaltefolie
darüber geben und das ganze bei
zimmertemperatur stehen lassen so etwa
für eine halbe stunde für stunde bis
sich der hefeteig verdoppelt hat also so
ist weder jetzt aus und dann zeige ich
ihnen euch gleich eine aufgegangen ist
mein hefeteig ist aufgegangen so sieht
er jetzt aus und stecken jetzt einfach
noch mal kurz ab denn ich muss jetzt als
die füllung vorbereiten und für die
füllung habe ich hier jetzt 200 gramm
marzipanrohmasse ich habe 200 gramm
mandeln ein bisschen milch so etwa 100
milliliter und zwei teelöffel zimt und
ihr könnt es natürlich auch gemahlene
haselnüsse wandel nehmen
ich habe die ganze und setzte einfach
wechseln
dann gebe ich das marzipan dazu einfach
so in kleinen stückchen und gleich ein
bisserl mich erst mal die hälfte und den
zins so ungefähr zwei teelöffel zwar aus
wie zwei esslöffel aber machte sich
marketing und einfach nochmal mixen
nein
die füllung ganz kurz zur seite stellen
und wer jetzt den teig ausrollen dafür
habe ich mir erzählen dass telefonate
vorbereitet und die so ein bisschen
gemailt bei mir und da kommt jetzt der
teig aus der riecht auch richtig gut
und jetzt soll ich diese griffen teig
einfacher aus so groß wie meine matte
also es sind dann ungefähr so 40 auf 60
cm und da streiche ich jetzt die füllung
drauf und wenn ihr das jetzt ohne
füllung machen wollt könnt ihr hier zum
beispiel ein bisschen butter drauf
streichen und auch auf vol
ich bin dann klicke hier zog nämlich
noch ein bisschen besser auf und wird
außerdem viel locker ab aber man kann
natürlich auch ohne butter machen
jetzt wird es nur noch von der langen
seite her aufgebaut
es ist eigentlich so ähnlich wie man
nutzer eben nur das monate sitzt
transfair mich dann gleich machen
jetzt hier meine silikon packte meine
silikon matte weg somit kann ich dass
mich drauf schneiden denn dann geht die
kaputt und jetzt musst du dass du ein
bisschen gleichmäßig formen
damit es auch gleich hübsch aussieht
und jetzt nehme ich mir ein scharfes
messer und schneidet hier ein
jetzt kann ich die zwei stränge einfach
übereinander legen so das lasse ich
jetzt hier noch offen
dann hier genauso
transportiere ich das ganz kurz herüber
jetzt könnte das schön zu einem kranz
formen
ich fand das jetzt hier nicht so ganz
schön also mache ich noch mal kurz auf
jetzt verbinde ich hier einfach die zwei
enden miteinander so und dann kommt das
hier darüber
da speziell ganz gleichmäßig aber das
ist nicht schlimm ich lass dir jetzt
nochmal abgedeckt ausruhen zur etwa noch
mal eine halbe stunde
damit er auch richtig schön locker wird
und danken wir ihnen gleich backen
mein lebenslauf ist aufgegangen und ich
muss sie jetzt nach bestreichen
ich habe es hier in einer schale drin
zwei eidotter zwei esslöffel milch und
so eine prise zucker und das
verkehrliche ist einfach hier einem
schneebesen geht auch unser gabel warum
ich so eine prise zucker drin sind hat
das ist business card normalisiert
gleich an der oberfläche
deswegen geborgen dann bestreitet es
einfach mit einem silikon pinsel dann
bekommt nämlich eine schöne farbe und
trug mit auch nicht aus die gestern
richtig schön gibt es eine geschichte
zum stop zur großstadt an social konsum
also ich hab gelesen das ist ja in
manchen regionen üblich ist dass wir
eben zustands und osterkamp macht bei
anderen sind andere gebäcke üblich ich
hab das jetzt einfach nach gemacht weil
ich einfach nur statt o auf seine panzer
und weil es hat richtig hübsch aussieht
als ich finde den richtigen dekorativ
und er geht hat total einfach aber er
könnte man mal schreiben was bei euch so
der brauch ist ob wir behaupten brauch
habt ja auch einfach so als
frühlingsopfer sicher auch schon zum
frühlings kannst musst eine demo stand
seit einem monat
wenn mir feuerwehr auch kein ostern oder
weihnachten wir machen es halt nur weil
man soll alles essen wollen und daher
alles gut
so ein silikon bin platt natürlich den
vorteil der haard halten hat bist du
normale halbinsel
deswegen habe ich eigentlich gar keine
halbinsel haben außer wenn ich zum
beispiel von trotten mache und dieter
bemale braucht nämlich ganz feine pinsel
aber so beim bestreichen telefonen ich
kann mir auch einfach nicht mein
hefezopf fährt jetzt im ofen bei 190
grad und hitze gebacken für etwa 35
minuten
ihr müsst einfach aufpassen dass er
nicht verbrennt aber so dass er ebenso
eine schöne goldbraune farbe kommt und
das machen wir jetzt und dann zeige ich
in euch wieder fertig ist
mai nosta cansiz jetzt gibt marken und
jetzt werde ich ihnen noch mit diesem
schnee bestäuben
ihr könnt auch puderzucker nehmen aber
puderzucker schmilzt immer auf warum
gebäck oder auch feucht und gebäck und
dieser schnee zucker bleibt einfach
immer schön drauf legen
man könnte jetzt natürlich auch ein
puderzucker kurs machen
das mache ich jetzt nicht dann wird mir
das wahrscheinlich zu süß wobei wenn man
den mit zitrone macht das sage ich auch
mal ganz lecker
das will ich ja nicht eigentlich auch
aber man hatte sie zu erzählen
mit dem süßen schnee und wer möchte kann
jetzt hier noch ein paar eier einlegen
dann auch richtig hübsch aus natürlich
noch schöner wenn man es selber färbt
eine kreativpause das kommt mit dem
steuer habe land doch jetzt mal was hat
es mit uns zu tun aber ich weiß nicht
wahr sein anders aus aber ihr wollt es
bestimmt auch wissen wieder von innen
aussieht deswegen schneide ich denn
jetzt mal an
und wenn ihr übrigens keinen marzipan
mit könnte ja auch zum beispiel die nuss
füllung von meinem mund aufmachen
das ist eine leckere musik schokolade
gefüllt oder ihr könnt diese platte mit
butter bestreichen und zimt zucker
drüberstreuen und ein paar walnüsse zum
beispiel so sieht jetzt von innen aus ja
ich bin probieren ich will dass
ausländische mehr einigen okay ich auch
wirklich aber mir ist es mir geht es mal
hier
danke bitte ich finde richter
leckerbissen das zitronige den markt an
die mandeln und ich bin zufrieden
super wirklich das freut mich ja schon
schön unser foto für instagram und für
facebook und wenn ihr dieses rezept nach
macht würde mich auch freuen wir nehmen
dann bild schickt oder mir einfach mal
schick mit was ihr das gemacht habt
vielleicht mag ja auch immer großen
kinderfest ihnen rein machen
ich kenne auch mit haag hat es auch sehr
lecker und ja ich finde es ist ein
einfaches rezept sieht aber sehr gut aus
also viele die noch nie in so ein
hefeteig gemacht haben fragen mich immer
wie geht so was sie zu kompliziert aus
aber ihr habt ihr gesehen ganz einfach
mit dem durchschneiden und ja eigentlich
dauert auch nicht zu lange also
insgesamt vom teig ansätzen bis zum ende
dauerte ungefähr zwei stunden oder
zweieinhalb wenn es länger gehen lässt
morath noch ein schlusswort oder ist
immer verlass ich finde ich will jetzt
noch den dem also ich vermisse ein
bisschen die die zitrone oder zuckerguss
also mir gefällt ich ganz ehrlich mir
gefällt es besser mit dem zitronen zu
tun das weil ich mag diese drohne die
heiße ich auch ich machen gleich noch
darauf ob ihr dürft schon mal abschalten
und ich werde euch noch die variante mit
dem futter zuckerguss auf meinem blog
schreiben er vermittelt oder sogar mit
zitrone anmischen darüber träufeln und
das ganze gibt's zum nachlesen auf sell
off - blog.de bis zum nächsten mal